-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny comedian
and the Emmy-nominated
co-creator
and star of "Big Mouth."
The fourth season
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-What the hell are you?!
-I'm Tito the Anxiety Mosquito
-Anxiety Mosquito?
-Bzz!
-Ow!
-I'm sorry.
People hate it when I do that.
People hate it
when I do everything.
But do I stop?
-Unh!
-You killed me!
I get it -- I'm the worst.
But so are you.
-I know.
Andrew hates me.
-And so does Seth.
They're probably
making fun of you right now.
-You think so?
-Here's what
they're definitely saying.
"Nick is a whiny little baby
Let's jerk off on his pillow."
[ Laughing ]
-No! Please stop
saying this stuff!
-You're gonna have
the worst summer.
Everyone's gonna hate you.
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend Nick Kroll.
Hello, Nick!
How are you?
-I'm good.
How you doing, Seth?
-I'm doing great, but probably
not as good as you're doing.
Recently married.
Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you very much.
I'm sorry
that you were not invited.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, I don't know if we had to
focus on that, but, uh,
all right.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was probably the best part
of the wedding was the fac
that it was like --
I mean, nobody was there.
It was just me and my wife
Lily, on a cliff in Big Sur.
But what I really --
what really brought me comfort
was that I knew you were
not gonna be there.
-[ Laughs ]
It was a, uh --
It was a beautiful photo.
And I will admit,
it must be nice
to not have the pressure
of deciding
who to invite to your wedding.
-It was.
It really was.
I mean, it was pandemic-related,
obviously, because of COVID,
but it definitely
made the guest list easier
by saying no one could be there.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, because, as you know,
sometimes people give funn
speeches at weddings.
-Yeah.
-Anyway...
-And they can get a little
close to the bone.
[ Both laugh ]
You, I would imagine that,
had you had your wedding
with guests, your friend
and co-creator of the show
"Big Mouth," Andrew Goldberg
would've been there.
-Absolutely.
-You guys have known each othe
so long, part of this season
as we saw from the clip,
takes place at summer camp
You guys
were in summer camp together
-Yeah.
-And there you are, rocking out.
-Yes. Yeah, that's a quality
picture of me and Andrew.
I've known Andrew Goldberg
since we were 6 years old,
and we became best friends
in middle school,
and he joined me at camp.
And so, the beginning
of this season of "Big Mouth
takes place at summer camp
And that is from --
that picture is from --
We did a lip sync
to Freddie --
Well, all of Queen's song
"Don't Stop Me Now."
And we were all wearing spandex,
some of us had jock straps on,
some of us had teddy bears
taped to our crotches.
It was --
We won, and the thing was,
we would do
this lip-sync competition,
and whoever won
that lip-sync competition
would then perform
at visiting day.
And we won, but our --
I think the powers that be
decided it was not the best song
for the parents
to see a bunch of pubescent boys
singing Freddie Mercury.
-When you look
at old photos like this --
Whenever I look at old photo
of myself, all I think is like
"Ah, remember
when thin was easy?"
-Yes, I had the same thought
I was like,
"Look at tiny jacked me."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "What happened?"
-Hey, one of the things
I was taken with,
with this show, is you know,
it's this very honest assessment
of everything kids go throug
in puberty, and it always,
like -- I'm reminded of it
as more than I remembered it
I'm like, "Oh."
Like, the trauma comes back.
And it must be helpful that,
one, you and Andrew
went through it together,
but, also --
I'm very impressed by this -
you actually --
you talk to, like,
teens from today,
which must be a very important
part of the process.
-Yeah, we talk to sex educators,
and, you know, sociologist
and people who write
about the stuff,
and then, through that,
we've ended up talking to, like,
teens and stuff who are in
like, sex-education programs
and, anecdotally,
I'll talk to kids, you know,
who watch the show
and dig into it.
And it really led us
to the theme of season fou
of the show,
which is all about anxiety
And I think kids today
are feeling heightened level
of anxiety.
More so, I think we all
felt anxiety growing up,
but then now,
because of social media
and phones in their pocket
and screens constantly,
it's just
this never-ending onslaught.
And I think
it's caused not only kids
but adults to feel
more anxious these days.
But we really try
to talk to kids
and get a sense from them
what they're going through
and anxiety and anxiousnes
is top of the list for kids.
And we started writing this,
you know, almost two years ago
not realizing that there was
going to be a global pandemic.
We thought there was just gonn
be a presidential election
Little did we know that
not only would there be
a global pandemic,
but we'd have a president
who refuses to concede his loss.
-You know, I'm very taken with
the amount of parents I have -
friends, I should say,
that are parents who have kids
who are in their teens
and they watch this as family.
Because, you know, obviously
it's super funny.
It can be really blue at times
But I think that, as parents
they really respect the fact
that it takes
all this stuff seriously
and doesn't dismiss any of it.
And I think, for them, it'
a tool to talk about the thing
that a lot of parents
don't know how to cross
that threshold into making the
topics of conversation.
Do you get that feedback,
as well, from parents?
-Yeah. I didn't --
You know, when we started
making the show, it was like
"Oh, well, let's make a show
that would make us laugh
and people like Seth,
who we won't eventually
invite to our weddings."
You know, like, we wanted --
But it really was.
And then, I came home.
I went to, like,
my nephew's bar mitzvah
after season one came out,
and my nephew Jacobi and his
friends were like, "Oh, my God
We watched the show!"
And then I saw their parents
who were like my brother and his
friends, and they were like,
"Thank you for having the show
so that we don't have
to talk to them
about these subjects."
Or it gives us, as you said,
a platform to talk about it.
So we're very conscious
of what we're --
what messages
we're putting out there
while simultaneously
trying not to hold any --
pull any punches
and make the show soft.
I mean,
the first couple of episodes
Andrew is at camp,
and he won't go to the bathroom,
and so he's got
this impacted poop
that is just
growing inside of him.
We decided to vocalize that.
So we have Paul Giamatti
as Andrew's impacted poop.
-[ Laughing ]
-So it's --
We're really going
highs and lows.
It's high-brow, low-brow.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- You know,
I've always thought
that John Adams was
the impacted poop of presidents,
so it makes sense
you would get Giamatti.
-Of course. I think that's
a very fair analogy.
-You were called the Picasso o
puberty by "The New York Times
this year, which just must be,
like, a tremendous outcome
to when you first
started doing this show.
Because that really, I think
also speaks to the high-brow
low-brow nature of it.
-It's truly, like,
Picasso is my favorite artist,
and I am my favorite comedian.
[ Laughter ]
So it all really worked out.
No, it was a very funny thin
to be called
the Picasso of puberty.
It was hilarious. And it's like,
whatever success I've had,
it's been lovely, but when
you're in "The New York Times,
like, to my parents
and my parents' friends,
that's, like,
this sign that you have made it.
Little did they know
that the article would then,
like, talk about, like,
me talking to a writers' roo
about my childhood small penis
and putting my penis
in a prison.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, you know, again,
highs and lows, highs and lows
-Yeah.
I feel like, I would imagine
your parents have that history
with you
through your whole life,
which is your successes
often came, like,
sort of tied to a thing
they were both --
They were, like,
proud to tell their friend
and then ashamed
to show it to them.
-Right, exactly.
It's like, yeah.
They would come -- And I used to
host a show with Jessi Klein
who voices Jessi on the show
and they had to come
to that show early on,
and we would be talking abou
having sex and all this --
And the terrible -- like,
having terrible sex and stuff,
and they would have to be like
"I guess I'm here
to support my son."
You know, like,
I picture parents coming to,
like, Boom Chicago and seein
you do something awful
to a bunch of drunk, stone
Dutch people and being like,
"I guess we're proud of our so
making money
doing the thing he likes?"
-Yeah. I think that
most of their takeaways --
Certainly my dad's was,
it would've been
a little funnier
if he was doing it.
I think that would --
-Yes. Totally. Totally.
-Hey, buddy, it is absolutel
a pleasure to have you here,
but it was even more
of a pleasure
to have you at my wedding.
That meant a lot.
-Well, I have to say,
it's a pleasure
being on your show, always
And I had so much --
I really did have such a blast
at your wedding.
Thank you for paying
for me to be there.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm so deeply sorry
that I was not able to invit
you to mine, very purposefully
But I will say, if I did
invite people to your wedding,
I would invite your next guest
Jeremy O. Harris,
to the wedding.
'Cause I think
he's so funny and so talented.
And if you haven't seen
his coronavirus mixtape
on Instagram, I highly recommend
watching them.
It's where I understand
the Internet better every day.
And if you -- I actually
have some extra tickets
to "Slave Play,"
if you want to buy them from me.
I can give you
a very good deal on them
if you're interested in that
Let me know.
-That's very kind of you.
I really appreciate it.
Congratulations again.
It's really awesome
to see you all the time.
-Thanks, Seth.
I appreciate it, buddy.